so the the the way we process
information the other environmental
stimuli is based on the neurons they
talk to each other the process and the
make a decision there are too many two
ways of communications one is they
through the release of neurotransmitters
the other one is they I mentioned
through gap junctions so the basic idea
is that we want to develop an new
genetically encoding non-invasive method
to image the gap junction communication
so it's based on the it's a channel
between cells we want in the one cell we
want to generate a specific small
molecule as a mediator and in the other
side the media the world goes through
the gap function and the in the kinetic
cell there's a sensor for this small
mediator so once we triggered one cell
there's a response in the other cell
then this demonstrate that these two
cells are communicated by gap junctions
that's the basic idea so so for now we
know that the main function for
electrical synapses is synchronizing
your own firing like those neurons are
connected by gap junctions they were
fired together so they will release
transmitters together if you don't know
how to code you spend more time on
boring stuff and be less efficient know
someone's opinion may contradict yours
why is my friend Alan it's all about
your perspective
who are we and what is the nature of
this reality Nihao everybody welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sockin we
are on site in the beautiful Beijing
China at the picking University School
of Life Sciences we are now going to be
talking about neural communication we
have dr. Ling woo joining us on the show
hi there you thank you so much for
coming on our show you really appreciate
it thank you okay there's gonna be a lot
of fun I'm really excited to talk about
Ling's work for those that don't know
she's a postdoc in the lis lab at Peking
University School of Life Sciences who
developed Paris an optogenetic method
for functionally mapping gap junctions
and you can find the links in the bio
below Ling let's start things off by
asking one of our favorite questions
what are your thoughts on the direction
of our world so yeah that's a very
interesting question and to be honest a
little bit pessimistic about the future
of humans why I I mean they so we've
done too much to the earth like someday
someday we will extinct like they
decline mate the environment the
resource though we're there many
scientists are working on solving those
problems but still I look at pessimistic
but this this fine is fine for the earth
for the universe
do we have a lot of people that come
onto the show and tell us that we have a
big challenge that we have to arise too
we have climate we have geopolitical we
have exponential technologies we have
all of these things that are happening
at the same time and we need more young
people and scientists and artists and
inspirational leaders to step up and
tackle these big challenges otherwise
the human species has big issues that we
face do you think one of the big reasons
why we have all the issues is because
we're disconnected from nature from what
sustains us what do you mean can't you
like like the air the food the water the
nature it sustains us and we're
disconnected from it so that's why we
have problems do you feel that way I
feel yeah sort of I feel we care we care
not enough about the nature where we're
selfish most of us
and yeah this is a big thing to is to
figure out this this Nash equilibrium
between how much time and resources and
energy I invest into myself in my own
sustenance and success and how much I
invest into the collective into society
into my family my community my country
the world this balance between those two
things how to harmonize them it's it's a
very complicated issue so I don't have a
good answer how how can we solve this
problem or yeah I'm glad that you bring
it up though because it's something that
is very close to our hearts we talk
about it a lot on the show so I'm glad
that you have a more realistic idea on
the direction of the world rather than
just you know naively you know
optimistic or super pessimistic it's
good to be realistic about how
challenging it is yeah let's talk about
your journey so who were you as a kid
growing up where were you born how did
you get interested in science tell us
about your story well I was born as a
the only children in my family
and from Iowa from Provence in the by
the Yangtze River so it's a long longest
river goes across the middle of China I
was born by the side of a river and I
yeah since I'm the only I was the only
children and child within a family I my
memory of all day when I was a child is
that it's quite a long way and I will
although I will play around I would play
around with other kids but they're more
often that was a lot in
in the home when my parents was we're
working yeah and then what were your
parents doing and what were you doing
that got you interested in science well
we were your parents doing there um
annalistic and mo is an Alyssia about
chemicals chemical analyst yeah yeah
yeah okay and then what were you doing
when you were young that got you
interested in science well I I was
pretty good at at math at chemistry and
biology when I was in my top middle
school in high school so obviously I
chose to become a stem students yeah in
college so because I so maybe it's very
a typical Chinese student for it yeah so
because I have the best scores for my
biology so I chose the biology and also
because I'm interested in the nature
yeah yeah I remember that I I liked a
lot that when we have a Spring Festival
spring holiday and the summer holiday my
mom will bring me back to my grand
parent's place with which is located on
the Ruhr region of the city in that
countryside yeah yeah I I loved the
forests the lakes
animals yeah yeah yeah that's good so
okay so so scoring really well in
biology plus your love for nature got
you to actually pursue biotechnology at
on who University yeah okay so now tell
us about that
what were you studying when you were
there so it's not really biotechnology
so so it's more general you need a
changer your bio then because it says
biotechnology so you know yeah in this
certificate itself out biotechnology I
mean it's more general mmm ice we
studied yeah plant botany anyone I mean
any more biology for valid yeah animal
biology yeah yeah and the microbiology
logic yeah so they're in the in our
university more more laps or are doing
boat any mmm-hmm and microbiology yes
yeah so we so by biotechnology more
related to using engineered my micro
microbes yeah generate products yeah
yeah yep engineering microbes to
generate products yeah yeah and I did a
little bit plant biology I went to a lab
and was focusing on a find out best
condition to induce the product a
product production of
garlic oh wow yeah yeah because it's a
very useful plant we can have products
out of it too okay garlic
yeah of garlic it's a healthy food yeah
yeah makes our breath smell there's a
lot yeah there's lots of there's lots of
good food with garlic yeah yeah yeah how
about the move to pecking University to
the School of Life Sciences here after
on whoo University how did that move
happen yeah so we I was engaged in the
summer camp summer campus here in
packing University also Chinese academic
this is Institute and yeah basically I
applied some universities as well as
Institute for the summer campus program
in my when I was third year thirty of my
college and I came to Beijing the first
time and yeah I then then the the
program goes like there will be a
introduction about different labs and
then you will be able to work in the lab
shortly for a couple of days if you if
you like and you can talk to the P I of
the light lab and that's when I met you
long so when I the first time I met him
it's really like he was still like a
college student
yeah that's when he just got back from
us just started his lap mm-hmm so I
didn't know that he is he was a P I
already so I thought he he is a student
college students so yeah then he he was
very enthusiastic talking to the new new
students because yeah one reason is
because he wants to recruit student to
his lab so then we have a talk we had to
talk and and I found by that time I was
I was already interested in neuroscience
okay because I think neurons are very
unique cells right you can talk to them
like you can stimulate them mean they
were firing potential and that time I
was interested in uh electrophysiology I
I did a rotation in a lab and also
impacting University only for a one week
they were there a new lab using
electrophysiology recording to study
neural neural functions and also a
degenerative disease diseases and in the
you long kept showing up in the main
hall in the building every day and every
day he will we can catch up him and that
we will have a talk we would have a talk
and we talked a lot and
he was a electrophysiology just and but
he wants to do a imaging this new lab
and I think it's it's also very
interesting
yeah imaging big I like I like things
like you can you can have the results or
the results immediately you know things
like it's very yeah and it's beautiful
yeah right it's very beautiful so so I
joined that and you it was really you
you got interested in neuroscience and
you wanted to like you really liked
being able to stimulate a neuron and see
action potential happen you saw also
this interest in being able to map
neural activity you wanted to be a part
of of doing that and see this immediate
immediate map the immediate results of
being able to map something so and the
combination of of course you coming here
right around the time that you long was
starting the lab and stuff so what about
how you picked what you were interested
in doing at the lab out of everything in
neuroscience so I yeah
the lab is more focused on technology
technology techniques developing new
techniques and the the topic I truth was
about relatively underestimated field
about elect about gap junctions or
electrical synapses so neurons will talk
to each other so the the the way we
process information the other
environmental stimuli is based on the
neurons they talk to each other
the process and the make a decision so
there are two mainly two ways of
communication one is they through the
release of neurotransmitters the other
one is they I mentioned through gap
junctions which both happen in the
synapse both neurotransmission and
electrical yeah they can have they can
happen both at the same synapses or gap
Junction is more broad they can happen
between not only the chemical synapse so
the chemical synapse can be a mix to
synapse with neurotransmitter release as
well as the channel so how do you know
if a synapse is both for neuro chemical
and for electrical or if it's just for
electrical how do you how do you know
that you can you can use
electrophysiology recording so imagine
eight it's a two cells okay it took two
cells um if you depolarize one cell you
stimulate one cell you can record that
if it's a excitatory cell yeah so you
stimulate one cell and you record the
postsynaptic cell yes the world give you
an action potential if the presynaptic
cell is a excitatory cell yes and if you
block the chemical synapse take this
block the neurotransmitter release you
can still record a signal and that's the
electrical that means that that has
electrical can you have a neuro
electrical communication yes not just
neurochemical
or be okay so out of do we know out of
all of the neurons in the brain do we
know how many of the connections like
what percentage of them are both
neurochemical and neuroelectrical versus
just neurochemical do we have any idea
mmm we don't know we don't know we don't
know yeah that's new technologies but
some are just neurochemical and some are
both neurochemical neuroelectrical and
some are just neuroelectrical G of three
either chemical electrical or both is
that right or not
I think I think they the the purple
there are no cells just electrical
coming together with Justin is just
electrical okay yeah so it's either both
or just neural chemical or the end or
they talk through a different way so
it's such as there's three cells three
cells for example there's three cells
okay these two only talks through gap
Junction electrical smell this to talk
through chemical synapse but for this
cell you have both electrical and the
chemical communication interesting yeah
interesting how many how many total can
be at addison apps can you have how many
nerves can be pointed at the same
synapse I sorry you were giving this
example of three right yeah yeah three
neurons in the same synapse yeah and
kind of its kind it doesn't have to be
the same synapse neuron can have them a
lot of synapses yes yes it kind of
reminds me of streets uh-huh
because you know if you have the streets
like this this can look like four
neurons you know with the synapse in the
middle right and if it's maybe only you
know we I
if I can make three so this so this is
two and then you know maybe this is like
three right something like that but this
is going that way in this but then like
I'm wondering could there be five or six
yeah one you're can talk to man yeah
yeah yeah one neurons connectors are
like a thousand or something right yeah
something ridiculously high but but then
that but out of out of one synapse spawn
at one space is that synapse can be for
two neurons working before three or four
or no and I think for one just one
synapse yeah perhaps it's only a unique
mm oh you mono Oh unidirectional or mono
directional one-way yeah okay it happens
rarely that maybe there in some cases
there may be more than two neurons and
one of my new ones cuz you're gonna take
two
okay because you gave the example of
three but I mean different synapses
different part of the neuron or if the
the the chemical released for for the
chemical synapses the released
neurotransmitter can propagate can
travel long distance if they're stable
they can you know along the way they can
talk to many neurons other cells okay
this is already so interestingly cool
and fascinating so okay what is so
what's the you you called a an
electrical synapse is a gap Junction yes
and the normal or traditional synapse is
where neural transmission can occur that
as neurochemical which is like dopamine
serotonin or
in Africa etc okay so know what so we're
still trying to figure out how many are
traditional synapses versus also
electrical synapses and your specific
study is on electrical synapses gap
junctions yes okay yes so this is so but
you have a nice visual of this and we
can embed the visual here but you have a
you know a you have a presynaptic side
and you have a post synaptic side and
here's the synapse what are what are
these called again at the ends and
dendrites the ones are done exon this is
dendrites recent yes presynaptic is axon
yeah postsynaptic is dendrite yeah okay
axon synapses end right okay axon
terminal is Oh excellent terminal and to
the dendrite these two membrane
consistent consisted a Phoenix the
structure okay an axon and then axon
terminal and then synapse and then
dendrite here on the other side yes yeah
okay and then on the axon terminal is
super complicated stuff that I have no
idea what I'm talking about
it's where the neurotransmitter released
but there's like vesicles right yeah
yeah yeah
so and the vesicles they already have
the neuro chemicals in them yeah in the
neuron picks which one to release out of
the vesicle they're bunch of vesicles
talking on the presynaptic region yeah
so in their potential sensitive Kelsey
and sensitive and yeah if you stimulate
the the neuron will
firing and the calcium will influx well
a calcium the well goes into the cell
and the trigger the membrane fusion of
the vesicle so they will whoa
yeah release all together whoa and is in
the vesicles different neuro chemicals
ready to go and then the neuron picks
which one it wants to they are the ones
terminal most of the time is just one
type of chemicals so all the vesicles
contain the same type of transmitter oh
okay yeah okay and a different axon
terminal but same neuron is different
neural chemicals that's a very
interesting question
and I think we don't right now we don't
have a clear answer to that and that's
why the method our lab developed it's
very useful if you check how other
episode of yours yeah about that
neurotransmitter sensors mm-hmm
so so there are peptide
neurotransmitters and small chemical
neurotransmitters they can happen they
can be synthesized in the same neuron
like for this neuron but let's say that
dopamine neuron they can't not only
release dopamine but also cava and for
other neurons they can also they can
release GABA and neuropeptide so but how
do different type of modulators in one
cell being controlled to release yes
interested in short restriction not
clear yet okay
yeah okay so the neuron has some sort of
of
modulation mechanism inside of it that
did that based on what's happening in
the environment as it gets stimulated
picks which neurochemical Werner
electrical signals to pass on through
its axon terminals to other neurons yeah
this is crazy okay okay
different type of stimulation different
state of your brain like some can happen
very soon some can is a chronic of
affect yeah okay so okay so let's talk
about then you picked electrical
synapses why did you pick electrical
synapses versus studying neurochemical
transmission so the rationale it was
very simple I chose to study something
less people study yes yes very good yes
walk down the path that there's less
people walking down yeah yeah yeah less
yeah more scientific discovery potential
potentially who knows yeah yeah okay
okay okay can so continue that was the
decision but then how do you you know
you start with okay so I've picked the
electrical synapses now what the heck do
I do how do I even come up with
something like Paris Lee you know yeah
so they're relatively so right now or
before this strategy developed they're
not too many or if almost none of the
methods to investigate investigate gap
junctions which are non-invasive or
genetically encoded so we want them so
the basic idea is that we want to
develop and new genetically encoding
non-invasive
a method to image the gap junction
communication by non-invasively I mean
those existed methods they are either
used I mentioned the electrode recording
you will poke the cell damage the cell
body the membrane integrity and all yeah
so basically that's the traditional way
where you inject dye which also damage
the cell so we want we don't want to
damage the cell we want to remain the
cell itself complete there yes and so
imaging is a very good method the light
is relatively non-invasive yeah so so
the idea was used an amazing way to you
mean yeah to get signals from Cape
Junction on communication so how do we
create the signal so we came up the
basic principle based on the there's a
channel gap Junction is a channel so
this is so mind-blowing keep going yes
are you still there yeah yeah I'm just
with jaw dropped just trying to compute
all of the information yeah okay you
going so it's based on the it's a
channel between cells so we want it we
want in the one cell we wanted to
generate a specific small molecule as a
mediator and in the other side of the
the median will goes through the gap
Junction and the in the connected cell
there's a sensor for this small mediator
so once we triggered one cell there's a
response in the other cell then this
demonstrate that is two cells are coming
get it by gap junctions that's the basic
idea so there's a so so Paris has to
have one on the on the presynaptic has
to have an actuator yeah an edge
generator and on the postsynaptic has to
have a reader yeah a sensor a sensor a
reader and then you when you see
electoral activity this actuator can be
controlled it can be controlled yeah
okay if we activate the actuator it will
generate feel like my smartphone or like
how do I handle how do you like click a
button and write your the neuron
activity how do you do that how do you
do that first part I don't know whether
you have heard of observe geniux
optogenetics so through light sir lights
yes yeah exactly
you'd like to stimulate you stimulate
the actuator and the actuator actually
is a proton pop it's a proton pump
light-sensitive proton pump okay okay so
basically you're using the proton as a
signal as an actuator as the media as
the media the protons the mediator yeah
activate the actuator by the light by
the way well okay give you the mediator
which is proton which is proton proton
can readily go through the channel yes
okay and Edie connect yourself there is
a sensor for proton proton yeah and then
that sensor you read out the data from
that sensor how do you read out the data
from that sensor that the proton oh yeah
that's a fluorescent protein I think
will emit fluorescence
can be collected by the microscopy okay
oh yeah okay okay so you're literally
stimulating with optogenetics on one
side and then you're you're cascading up
a proton to go across to the other cell
that then is read out through microscopy
by fluorescence on this other side and
then you know that the proton success we
made it across which means this is an
electrical synapse and these two neurons
are talking to each other yeah and
that's how you know a little bit of
knowledge about neural communications
yeah like you wonder what types are
communicated by gap junctions you can
put the actuator in one type of cell the
sensor another tell a type of cell and
stimulate one cell and you may need the
other cell well that's it that's the
idea
yeah and we tried it and it worked as we
expected nice yeah that's always nice as
a scientist let's set up this experiment
we think it's gonna work and then you do
it and it works and you can repeat it
and you can get papers published and
hopefully other scientists can use it
use it and build on it and then then we
know the chemo connectomics better and
then in this case would be the electro
connectomics yeah or you can add them
both chemo electric connectomics
or electro chemo connectomics
is so buddy the words are so good but
they're all encompassing which I like
about it and in this case it's literal
literally you're only doing one to one
neuron but down the line you can
possibly do maybe a hundred at the same
time to try and see like big picked more
big picture a neural communication
that's one of the goals
is that right more big picture you're
all communication yeah we the fact is
that we we don't for now we don't know
yet which type of neurons because
they're so many neurons in the brain
which of them are talking through gap
junctions we don't actually know as a
whole picture we know some but that's
only a very small part of it and how how
it being regulated how its country goes
to chemical synapses yeah yeah
yeah I asked you that at the beginning
and that's a really interesting point is
just what is the deal with electrical
synapses versus ones that are
neurochemical versus ones that are both
neuro chemical and electrical there's so
much information in this conversation
which has been so interesting yeah okay
continue you're about to say something
so so for now we know that the main
function for electrical synapses is
synchronizing your own firing like those
neurons are connected by gap junctions
they were fired together so they will
release transmitters together electrical
synapses are used to synchronize in many
ways neuron neuronal communication
synchronize so yeah that's one of the
function one of the functions yeah yeah
okay yeah the others like it because
it's can also I have a question so so
would it be like if I'm taking in some
sort of a stimuli that is maybe becoming
more more frequent in my life maybe it's
like I'm going on like the same route to
school or maybe it's I'm eating the same
food or drinking the same water or
talking to the same person or hearing
the same thing or seeing the same thing
that would it then be that that those
that that neural communication is
synchronizing through gap junctions to
make it a little bit more efficient
because I'm taking in the same stimuli
hey I think that's a little bit
different yeah I repeated stimuli you
probably are strengthened or
strengthening the connection between
neurons as you're constantly stimulating
the same circuits till they those
neurons were not as connected as at the
beginning but you keep stimulating them
at the same time so they become more
connected so yeah that yeah what would
be an example of neural synchrony then
with gap junctions like why well what
outside stimuli in the environment would
cause neural synchrony for me through
the gap junctions it's a constantly open
channel so it happens almost all the
time like those neurons have kept
junctions they will file together they
any stimuli can stimulate this neuron
they they will fire together it's it's
constantly open there so the connected a
bunch of neurons for example in the
cortex the inter neurons the inter
neurons are abundantly connected with
cap junctions the inter neurons function
is to modulate the primer in your own
which are the real executors to to do
the job to control your behavior so if
but internals can
connect to with can regulate the
activity of the primary neuron so then
those internals are connected by cab
junctions yeah so they can fire together
so they can regulate the barn trolls
from earlier on together so how do you
know what's a primary neuron versus a
connector neuron does the primary neuron
start that the signal transmission
premarin your own have long synapses
have long synopsis yeah they have long
projection synapses a long projection
services okay
yeah and condemn ourselves shorter inter
neurons
inter neurons inter neurons they they
they look different morphological they
are different primarily I have this long
axon and throughout different layers of
cortex okay
primary neurons have a longer axon and a
longer synapse and inter neurons so
primary neurons are the neurons go to
who does the job to control behavior
because they connect they have this
projection projected axons to control
other neurons to control motor neurons
okay
yeah motor neurons do toxic behavior
yeah its activity are regulated by
internal house yes
our primary neurons primarily located in
the cortex and in the weak especially
the prefrontal cortex or what although
all over the cortex
okay and then their long axons go to
inter neurons which are then in lower
more like limbic structures they they
project to they control they it's very
complicated
so mmm they don't project to inter
neurons they project to other primary
neurons primary talk to other
oh the limbic talks to other primary
where were yeah where were we on that
point again I was thinking about the
cyclical potential but I know you you're
trying to make me come up with some
examples about gap junctions function
right yeah and you were talking about
like the inter neurons have smaller and
smaller they don't have a projection
exons make going so you don't have
projection axons yeah yeah okay inter
neurons don't have projection axons yeah
yeah if you if you see a typical picture
for cortex with six layer of cortex the
primary neuron can go through all the
layers like inter neurons can stay in
the ones with one different there are
many different type of new generals in
different layers yeah
but the primer and the oils spend all
the layers oh my gosh even the site the
even understanding like how what a
primary neuron does compared to an inter
neuron
so interesting okay for another
conversation okay so to the applications
let's talk about of Paris okay so what
happens when you are using this
optogenetic Li stimulated proton pump
and then reading out the via
fluorescence that sounds really cool but
like what can it be you know apply for
so in the paper we we showed an
application is to map the real location
of electrical synapses as I mentioned
URLs have complex morphology their axons
and dendrites but in a sub cellular
level where does the electrical synapses
where does this channels localize on the
cell it's hard to study by other methods
so their self their cell body they have
a bunch of processes they can overlap
they can overlap with each other so at a
different site of those processes or it
between cell body contacts so how do you
locate them locate the channel using
this Paris method you can control the
light you can spot the lights at
different sites locally to induce the
signal and to see where the channel is
if you spot the light activate the
channel on the dendrite and it gives you
a signal but if you stop the earth
stimulate the light the actuator on the
axons you don't observe
signal that might indicate that those
two cells communicate through dendritic
dendritic interaction that's one example
for the application mm-hmm yeah yeah we
have spatial resolution and the
localization of the channel in different
sides of the cell might might indicate
something forth for how this turnaround
can communicate more efficiently and
yeah we don't actually know such as if
the if the channel is localized on axon
it might more be more internally to
propagate see to make the cell more easy
to fire easier to fire together yeah so
basically they have spatial resolution
and for other and application examples I
can come up like for drug screening gap
Junction not only exists in the brain
actually it also exists abundantly in
the heart
so they synchronize the firing of heart
muscle making your heart contract yeah
so they mmm the cap junction blocker
so it's used as a drug to protect hearts
from infarct ischemia so we can use the
the this message is screwing more drugs
that otherwise block gap Junction
communication or regulate gap Junction
communication yeah can do this in vitro
screening okay so you have
pharmacological applications also just
larger neural mapping and communicative
of applications okay
okay because I can again get lost in all
of the weeds of what you were just
talking about where is so much nuance
but that's we can maybe even get into
another part of this of a deeper dive
into the brain science with you on all
these applications at another time
because I just know that this is like
way more nuanced like you were talking
about ions earlier right I have no idea
that ions were even a part of the brain
neuro communicative process I don't even
know that well you know what I mean like
that ions are a part of it that there's
primary neurons and inter neurons that
that there's I should just a little a
better example well this is also you're
trying to teach about the edge of
complexity to a big which we're trying
to bring that down like explain like I'm
5 to 2 to me into other people and it's
very it's a very hard one to do like
electrical synapses versus
traditional synapses with neuro
chemistry versus just electricity okay
so what are the the applications for
health and disease of this are mostly
like you were saying of just having a
better idea of mapping out neural
communicative infrastructure plus
pharmacological understanding is like
what where would you see like the most
ideal applications of this technology in
health in health yeah there are some
disease diseases caused by the mutation
of channel protein the one of them is
caught Oh DDT it's a I didn't remember
the complete name but in developmental
disease so the patient will suffer from
abnormal development of their digital
like fingers toes and teeth in jail yeah
the day their higher cognitive function
also infected and not abnormal and its
cost of either a bunch of mutations on
the on the protein one type of the
channel protein connecting forty-three
so
you're asking about health health so how
how this method can help with health I
think we can use this method to study of
the diseases caused by the mutations of
the junction channels interesting
diseases caused by mutations of the
junction channels mm-hmm interesting so
there's mutations that happen at gap
Junction channels and those mutations
cause diseases okay okay okay now I'm
following okay and so yeah we can
prevent those diseases by studying how
those mutations happen at gap Junction
channels and either prevent them from
happening or heal them maybe and at the
mechanism level how how those mutations
affect gap Junction communications
whether this mutation caused disease by
the abnormal by alternate altering the
gap Junction communication yeah because
it seems like so many of our diseases
are related to miscommunications and so
if there's a miscommunication happening
at that gap Junction then it may be a
leading to a serious disease yeah
because some some mutations might mm-my
some mutation might affect communication
but some may not so so what indeed a
mutation contributes a disease and it
happens in a channel protein so it's it
will be useful to test that
to test results consequence of the
mutation mm-hmm how about on a on an to
continuing our conversation about other
disease states of the brain and how
those are issues of miscommunication or
other the neural communication just
issues in general where do you see all
of the neurological diseases that would
pick up and I mean neuro degeneration
happens usually at end of life but we're
talking like 10 year old 20 year old 30
year old like really young people are
experiencing anxiety depression OCD ADHD
blah blah blah blah blah they're like
endless all the issues what do you what
do you what insights do you have about
the development of those and why do you
think they're happening and how do you
think we can heal them that's a very big
issue and we don't have a clear answer
what exactly happened in the brain
having those psychiatry disease now but
something we knew is that
for those brains so so it's many
happened like two levels one is the
molecular level the other is the circuit
level so for the molecular level like
they we we know that the low level of
dopamine low levels serotonin associate
is associated with diseases such as
depression so that's it's a that's a
molecular level and on the 30 levels
is the connection between your eyes
there's something wrong with the
connections either they region that
controls say negative emotion the
connection are strong strong
strengthened or the connection with a
positive is too weak yeah it can yeah so
molecular Li the issue is about low
levels of serotonin or dopamine and
circuitry
it's either negative circuitry is too
strong or positive circuitry is too weak
that's mine it's your understanding yeah
I like that understanding a lot yeah
yeah like if someone's like hyper OCD it
might be like I've had like several
times where I've seen like these two
there's like two hairs on the table over
here and I've been like well maybe I
actually just like brush them off like
that you know like what's going on in my
brain that's that's so strongly wired
that I must go and do that or is it you
know too weak of wiring about like
retaining or paying attention here or
whatever it may be or too strong of
wiring of paying attention to all these
other aspects of the environment or
whatever whatever it is hmm
depression especially and has a lot to
do with societally like sociologically
has a lot to do with being at the bottom
levels of hierarchies like people at low
levels and hierarchies that don't have
shelter don't have water don't have food
that are constantly struggling to get by
are just harder for them to have high
levels of happiness and low levels of
depression but there's a weird scenario
where there's people around the world
that have none of that stuff but they're
also really happy yeah which is very
strange because then you wonder well
what are is the the chemo connectomics
of their brain where they're totally
happy when they have nothing but then
these people have nothing but they're
totally unhappy how is that happening
yeah that's that's interesting and which
reminds me of people when people do they
research mice they will they will use
some way to make the my stress and they
will always found that some of group of
men some mice will be depressed and the
other mice will be resilient yeah so
there has to be something about the
innate state 50 brain that's pretty
interesting too it's like how that could
be an interesting question for chemo
connectomics or just circuitry
strengthening or weakening in terms of
just how how someone is resilient to
stress compared to others and is that
have something to do with that but
genetics is that something to do with
ancestral genetics leading up to this
point there's a lot one way to
this is or powerful tool to study this
is single cell are asic single-cell RNA
sequencing yeah why why a single cell
RNA sequencing so useful because it's at
the it looks at the transcription to
transcriptome level what what protein
has a different expression level like
what so people can compare the mice with
higher resilient and lee hi's mice day
and says get the t by sequencing the RNA
you can see what a genetic differences
between high resilience mice versus low
resilience mice distress yeah I think
damn RNA is so interesting yeah RNA
sequencing can give us phenotypic
phenotypic phenotype poll data yeah I
can can give you more ad but we don't
know maybe you we will have you will
find out the bunch of genes a lot of
genes
so yeah you by combining with other
methods and things we already know it
can provide you some candidate at the
molecular level to study to go further
[Applause]
gosh Wow okay I'm also really interested
in how on the flip side of what we were
talking about sociologically there's
lots of rich people that are high up on
hierarchies that have high serotonin
levels that don't experience depression
and there are also lots of rich people
at the top of hierarchies that have low
levels of serotonin that have high
levels of depression which is like the
opposite it's the same thing we were
talking about about the bottom but it's
the opposite in terms of people at the
top having a similar effect so there's a
lot of interesting things sociologically
and then molecular lean circuitry oh man
gotta love complexity gotta love
complexity it's a lot to understand
scientifically a lot to probe and try
and like weigh variables and understand
the nuance of these things how about
what would be your ideal neuroscience
tool what would give you ultimate power
of an understanding the brain so I think
there's three aspect we need to consider
one is how how neurons connected the
connectome oh of course it's very
important and the other thing is we we
need to put Erb a single at a single
neuron level to see so at the first
level we need to connect on we need a
circuit we need we know we know the
circuits we already know the the neurons
how it connects
and the second set we need to prepare
perturb it at a single cell level either
by so now we have the opto genetic
methods or other method chemo genetic
method to perturb it and we took perturb
it we can know something about its
function the third thing is molecular
level
you control the different protein
molecules in them neuron so you like in
pathologic current condition your
editors know that for example you
already know this neuron activities
changed but what caused it what's a
molecular target basis so you need to
have the third strategy to control
perturb the protein at the protein level
yeah I like your level so combine those
things different levels I think and more
comprehensively for us to understand how
the brain function I like that I wonder
how that would be packaged in like a -
in like one tool that could do
connectomics perturbation and molecular
level you cough I don't think you can
it's all possible everything is possible
we have to just design it we have to
design it
it's possible with the designers I and
also I as I mentioned the single RNA is
sick it's a very powerful lever I just
think one database one comprehensive
database about you incorporate all the
information we have like the
connectomics information can connect on
information and a single RNA seek
information and their date that behavior
related the behavior and the disease
mutations if we have all the
informations at a single neuron level
and at the at the same database like we
can we have a mouse brain we can click
when you're on them we can see the cell
connected to which cell and the wherein
locates and we can also see this the the
epoch the genomic of the other
transcriptome of the cell yeah and what
would have been done related to the
behavior is results that's what be
useful yes that to me that sounds like a
big simulation model of your brain and
me being able to look like click in and
look through but I would also have to
have like a history of your life
experiences that have caused your brain
to become exactly what it is today and
like yeah it's all I want to build a
digital twin of you and me of everyone
was built which is where we're heading
in many ways what about how can we
inspire more people around the world to
work together because here we are in
China doing these partnership interviews
here you are about
do your postdoc in the United States
people around the world to go to other
countries around the world and make
friends and make relationships it's very
important yeah how can we better work
together how can we better walk together
ah I think for for the P I in the lab
the group leader in the lab they they
should encourage students more to attend
more conferences and talk to people from
different it go more to the like happy
hour and encourage them to joint attend
those events activities and give them
opportunities to present their work more
often hmm yeah I like that a lot
okay and then what do you think is a
skill that young people should develop
as we move into the exponential
technology age coding why why do you say
that because it's really powerful and
that it can make boring stuff take less
time from you
I don't know I feel like everybody can
code if if if you don't know how to code
you spend more time on boring stuff and
and be less efficient
coating is also a way of perceiving the
world in algorithms or in loops there's
so many yeah training or logic train
your logic really well yeah yeah what do
you think is the meaning of life that's
a really big question I think the
meaning of life is
is to make any contributions you can
they're like that it's good
what about where do you think
consciousness originates from
consciousness
so
seems like basically consciousness
consciousness is the activity of neuro
you think it comes from the biology of
our body that it doesn't come from
somewhere beyond the body no okay yeah
yeah and then what about what he thinks
the relationship between free will and
determinism so you mean do we have free
will what do you think I think we do why
do you think so
why don't we oh why do you think we have
free well why don't we have free well
but like I mean can you give me some
examples other people I think don't
don't have they don't think we have free
will
well okay I was telling you a little bit
about this before the show started
there's examples of people that I've had
a tumor pressing against their little
MIG Dilla and they went out and killed
people their own family members okay
there are other examples of people being
able to look back at your behaviors over
millions of years the evolution of human
behavior that evolution of microbes over
billions of years before us that are now
housed inside of our guts that are very
much in control of what our actions do
you think it's you going to the
refrigerator to get food or do you think
it's your microbes telling you to go to
the fridge to get food
if if it's my crew this is the micro
being or got to tell you together food
it's still you where is you where is you
where is me is it into my brain and my
heart and my gut is it in my body or is
there no me is there no you is this
physical boundary of our skin not
actually a regular boundary but we're
really all interconnected at a way
deeper level than what looks like
physical difference
ah
I've thought about this question do we
have free will but I still think we have
so it's like Europe your well is still
in you
the things you've been through like who
you are
the example we raised liked it they
their patient have a tumor on their
admitted other will go killed people
doesn't mean they don't have free will
well if they would have had free will
would have they've been able to make the
decisions than themselves to not kill
their family so in that case is a
biology that has created something like
a tumor that is pressing against my
amygdala causing me to go do something
just like biology like the microbes in
your gut causing you to go and get food
just like what is you is you your
prefrontal cortex is you your brain or
your heart or your gut where is you is
you in this body is you outside of this
body do you have a relationship with
Europe with a higher self because these
questions are crucial they're critical
questions because many people are overly
wrapped in their egos and it doesn't
give us greater collaborative potential
when we're too wrapped up in our own
egos looping us back all the way to what
you said at the very beginning about
selfishness
I don't know I think it's kind of
intermediate we we kind of have free
well but we also kind of don't have it
what is the role of love in life it's
very important tell me about why is it
well these are the role of love
so like for example for that the being
reports babies born with less parental
caring you will be more they will feel
more insecure when they grow up
yes so love is important as the
beginning of your life
yes you if we all live in life in the
environment with a lot of love it will
help you become also a person film and
more coffee than insight you have more
stressing set sight yourself which will
make you more willing to give love to
others yeah and if we could all work on
that love within ourselves that we can
then also give to others than our world
a lot of those problems we were
initially mentioning at the beginning
just take care of themselves better last
question what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world I think in
my opinion is the ocean why
it's I'm looking for a word its Angeles
it's mysterious and it's powerful and
every time I look at the ocean I am
standing beside a beach looking at the
ocean I will feel feel calm I'm a big
fan of diving yeah I every time I go
under the water I I can feel calm or
calm and it's just amazing the
underwater see those animals living
there amazing in plants the chorus and
the we yeah we need to pay more
attention about protect our ocean yeah
what a beautiful answer this has been
such a fun episode laying thank you so
much for coming on our show thank you
thank you
it's such an honor this is so fun so
mind blowing across so many different
aspects thank you thank you thank you
thank you thanks everyone for tuning in
we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on the episode let us know what you're
thinking have more conversations with
your friends families co-workers people
online about neural communication in
general the conversations we were having
about electrical synapses about the
chemo electro Connect omics about all
this crazy stuff and what it means for
our future for our health for our
longevity have more conversations about
building better tools to study the brain
and sharing those around the world also
check out the link in the bio below two
more of links work into you lonely lab
org and all
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the leaders the organizations around the
world that you believe in sports
simulation our links are below help us
continue doing cool things like coming
on site to China for more continued
partnership interviews and go and build
the future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we love you very much
thank you for tuning in and we will see
you soon peace
[Music]